today's video is brought to you by
manscape comm manscaped is the only
man's brand dedicated to below the waist
hygiene and grooming baby
it's the perfect tools for your family
jewels
I used to use scissors to trim my ball
sacks at one time I got a little too
close to the skin and cut a sack Oh big
time it was traumatic after that I said
I'm just gonna let it grow but then
girls won't like you when it's all blue
they do not like it so if you have one
of these guys check it out they got this
new technology or it's skin safe there's
even the light so if you're embarrassed
about shaving you could shave in the
dark so your mom thinks you're sleeping
but you're actually just shaving their
nuts yeah and you can shave your little
nuts like this and look how safe this is
and you can see like this look when you
have it like this you can see your child
no it's hard to reach places right where
it connects your butthole to your nuts
yep you can actually finally see it
which is pretty important look at that
and also if you're an astronaut you
might need a buddy to help you shave
each other cuz you guys just floating
around so it's kind of hard to help
stabilize yeah now you could see you
know like hey get back here but the cool
thing is that they have this mat here so
when your ball hairs flies to the ground
you can use this to catch it but that's
hard to catch in space because the hairs
are kind of just going oh so you're
maybe you could use this as like a net
like a spaceman yeah glad the ball here
is that a flag around the Space Shuttle
yeah we're huge fans of the manscaped
perfect package 3.0 kit 3.0 it's the new
new new
it's the perfect starter kit to make
manscape being safe and easy look at
that when you purchase the perfect
package 3.0 kit this is what you get you
get the lawnmower 3.0 which is the body
trimmer
so it's waterproof and cordless and it
has a USB charging dock look at that BAM
nice and neat you also get the crop
preserver anti chafing ball deodorant
and you get the co-op Reviver it's
refreshing ball toner spray we have the
magic mat which is also our version of
the astronaut ball hair catcher and you
get the replacement blade delivered to
your door every three months and because
you're a fan of us you get two free
gifts you get the anti chafing cooling
boxer briefs and you get the shed travel
bag this is nice so go to manscape calm
music ojk needs to get 20% off your
order plus you get two free gifts go
there now
man get calm every shipping Oh a free
[ __ ] get free shipping free shipping and
ladies this gift makes the perfect
Valentine's gift for your man's so go
get it now so one more time what a
mascara calm use J can use get 20% off
and free shipping and to fre gifts see
you later
link down in the description box below
baby alright so you know how that's
Mexican you know people with my culture
muted access they like to drink you know
especially the men I heard about that I
think I'm in a Mexican family I think I
must be in a Mexican family
I'm not saying only Mexican I have to
say Mexicans you know let her finish I'm
feeling I'm feeling it okay so what I
was trying to get at is that this woman
in Mexico she's from Sinaloa and so her
husband he just drinks a lot he's he's a
binge drinker and so she just kind of
got sick and tired of it and she started
lacing her husband's beer with a cat a
mixture of castor oil and plum extract
whoops we started quitting putting a few
drops into his beer bottle so he can get
a mild gradual laxative effect so he was
she was tough she was trying to convince
her husband that he had developed this
allergy talkable pass for me it's a
[ __ ] I Love Lucy episode
but what ended up happening though oh no
like so then like her husband's like uh
Jose he started getting you know little
like bubble guts but he was like I miss
you she comes in she was like ah you
know if I feel that I don't know how
you're drinking honey like maybe you
should not and then he was just like you
know I'll just pop some so medicine and
I'm good and so he's like though he made
a joke he said the bed was not even that
far away that pissed her off
she put even more oh and I got to the
point like his diarrhea got so bad like
he couldn't even make it to the bathroom
anymore so she just [ __ ] on us to the
hospital
and that's when at the hospital is like
eventually she ended up confessing what
happened cuz you should I've been
drugging you drink anymore you know I
just wanted you to to do not be really
[ __ ] drunk then all the time other
doctors like loves castor oil is [ __ ]
what test that is missing a lot lately
is he um does he have a what do you call
it like that like an eating disorder you
know how like when people get addicted
to laxatives mm oh yeah my strange
addiction is [ __ ] damn oh yeah man I
don't know like if I was reading the
story and I'm like yeah Mexican men love
their beer man they really do huh yeah
it's not gonna be him developing this
allergy for beer then eventually he's
gonna get cirrhosis so well not people
like to drink I feel like yeah we are a
weird breed of people because we didn't
I mean aside from Steve we didn't come
from a family that drinks a lot but I
know a lot of people that drink of
[ __ ] on my dad my grandpa my grandpa
died of liver failure end-stage liver
failure what's the roasters of drinking
never disease
now I'm doubting myself I thought that's
what it was III think it's definitely
related to drinking cirrhosis of the
liver a lot of my family so they drink
like socially like for parties but they
weren't like drinking all day long yeah
kind of I think I've only seen my dad
drunk once Mike
Dave for dinner that wine was part of
this thing but I didn't he wasn't like
pounding beers all day yeah so I saw how
liquor was enjoyed by him but like maybe
because my own allergies to it I never
really drink them my grandpa was an
alcoholic and then he uh he spent all of
the family fortune
he sold four homes and on hookers and
and and gambling down and I think that's
why I chose that nobody was like I'm not
touching [ __ ] alcohol that's what
movies are made of right you don't want
to hear my alcohol and movie story this
is boring as [ __ ] so so you sell for
homes and you'd spend on hookers yeah
did your movies like Grandpa comes home
has a glass of wine with his [ __ ]
ribs Mozart playing in the background is
very [ __ ] boring you have allergy to
alcohol
I hope it's allergy but like when I
drink I get extremely red I get a
headache and then I gotta start itching
all over the place oh is that like just
beer is that like alcohol to like almost
all of it I think then as I get I'm as
I'm getting older I can tolerate it more
so now I could have like a beer or two
yeah we drink a Modelo last night each
and it was like normally he gets like
purple like this bag I kill it turn like
really really perfect but he was like he
just had a mild like blushing that's
easily my favorite beer oh my god I
can't drink about here I think I'm a
wheat now there's you know the Negro
that one the best one why did you want
to say is because I'm a negro
oh yeah yeah you can say black no cuz I
was just with my buddy Casey at the bar
the other day it's pronounced either by
the way
I know saying abuses go say Oh Casey at
the bar yes like two weeks ago right and
and and we were both talking about how
much we loved that beer that's our fair
one and I was like can I even order it
these days is that show like what do I
do
what do you mean what can like maybe my
black beard like yeah we got beers we
kinda like the blacks
later right negative I'm good the news
reporter did with the Los Angeles [ __ ]
you good Lakers and mix Knicks see it
was a BBC I think that they were playing
images of LeBron they don't know like
black people like it I thought of John
bodega
I wouldn't know who any [ __ ] British
artists of London like I just like John
bodega you didn't because they raise a
boy Jager Bomb Yaga there's no Dean is
made I don't really give a [ __ ] Billy
Dee Billy Dee no I don't accept the new
Star Wars about although although I
think he was the best part of that movie
we're not going there
we're not where are we going then what
we going to keep talking about da Wars
yeah here's my fear in five minutes off
camera anyway good beer person I love
being like hard liquor I like hard
liquor for mixing it's cool it's like if
I drink too much of it like I feel like
I need water or if I'm a burp a lot
yeah I used to love beer only yeah my
aqua hot like hard liquor and I don't
like that alcohol taste that makes my
nose goes like this I can get ready for
like oh I can't I can't drink alcohol
how do you do that I don't know it like
goes in oh you're doing it sorta anyway
so now I drink only gin and I like gin
oh yes compound tonic tea yeah
I like gin and ginger beer okay that
works oh my [ __ ] that's in case he makes
it so great that sounds good um but like
so now I I stay far away from beer
because then I would makes me feel
bloated and I feel like I gotta pee a
lot yeah don't even give me a break that
see you
is a PC I still love it I'm still with
it I like a good GMT I prefer tango rate
has this really nice citrus toilet I
mean I was - citrus gin and then I use
like a regular tonic but I use that one
lemon one line everywhere it doesn't
matter what gin it is Hendricks
Tangerang Sapphire Bombay is always 1
lemon 1 lime taste way better and it's
less calories than a banana what's the
difference only tonic and soda water and
mineral so ordered it has [ __ ] up has
known the car B's that tonic water has
talked whereas bottoms of events are
water the one that's hella bitter yeah
it has a small amount of sugar but it's
weird by itself it tastes like [ __ ] but
we mix it with gin it tastes good yes
good okay Joe contributing to the know
he likes gin he's like Jenny's case we
talked out to my only one I can drink
yeah he's not patronize I think they
want you to drink okay oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
you don't do whiskey I've tried it do
you like I gotta watch out for beer so
um I tried non-alcoholic beer and I
still got a headache so I think I have a
wheat allergy or something
oh man tell them more dude I tried
captain and coke and I got a headache
I tried uh like Jack and Coke and I got
a headache yeah I just got a watch out
so gin and tonics the only one that I've
had so far where I'm just chillin
weren't you would you do it today for
patreon we do what do we do we do a gin
patreon I want to try what she would
guess you make the gin and ginger beer
one yeah so he I guess it's called a gin
buck right like he'd go hold it in gin
buck but I'll order it in the bars and
they still don't like build like what
the [ __ ] is a gin buck so I'm like you
have a say yeah cuz there was yeah but
I'm in one day I got a little
adventurous and I'm like oh what if you
make it with a Dehaene rim and that [ __ ]
oh that's mom have you had oh dude have
you had ginger beer and tank
around with lime oh I forgot it's
crucial you have to have either lemon or
lime I like lemon lime still works it's
[ __ ] awesome wait that's it that's a
meal they're right oh no noodles now
middle is with the well vodka ginger
beer actually you can put I just learned
that you could put any liquor in it long
as you have the ginger beer and the lime
it could be like in Kentucky my oldest
with whiskey maybe it's a good meal yeah
it could be a gym meal the partner is
like oh the [ __ ] you're talking about
any like he doesn't know anything I
drank a whole bottle of you know those
wine coolers that taste like fruit punch
it's like this big it's like yellow or
red or whatever MD 20/20 I forgot the
name of it but we drank the whole thing
at the beach at night I got [ __ ]
wasted I [ __ ] the beach I went into
the water puked and I came grayza you
create a hole in the beach and then you
insert doesn't that hurt well the super
grainy they were what they told me that
was just [ __ ] humping the [ __ ] out of
the sand and they were laughing and I
got up I puked on myself and I went out
and I puked again inside of the water I
jumped in I [ __ ] washed it off and I
came back out alright
did you feel bad after the puking came
up you can jizz at least I seem to do
that my mom told me one time too I
started [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of a pillow
when I was drunk and I puked outside
okay we're not getting you drunk dude
please can I just say for the just to go
for this man at least he [ __ ] the
beach the beach didn't [ __ ] him mmm was
it consensual [ __ ] in the mate oh
thanks a wonderful drink by the way I
[ __ ] the ocean
[Music]
[Music]